so we've been covering this truck strike
in canada all week and at the end of the
week there are a couple of different
images that kind of float around your
head
picture the cops stealing the fuel from
the freezing truckers you picture the
smiling truckers talking about love and
waving canadian flags totally
non-threatening
but above all you remember the hysteria
of the people in charge as they look out
on this sea of working-class people who
are really sick of being pushed around
told what to inject into their bodies
the people in charge are extremely upset
about this hysterical
and it's hilarious you can just picture
our transportation secretary little pete
butter judge jumping up and down shaking
his little hands screaming at the truck
drivers get off my bridge you guys
get off right now
and it's not just mayor pete
you remember those angry tweets from
that cnn contributor lady who suggested
we should slash their tires siphon their
diesel fuel throw them in prison
they're all torquemada now
they're talking like they're scary
but keep in mind these are not displays
of power these this is not how confident
people talk these are squeaks of
impotence our leaders are furious at the
truckers because they know there's not a
lot they can do about the truckers they
don't know anything about trucks for one
thing how do you get a truck off a
bridge especially when it has no fuel or
tires they have no idea you just order
someone to do it it's kind of like uber
eats some guy trots out and removes the
truck
the problem is the people who drive the
trucks don't feel like following orders
anymore
they're ignoring pete but a judge
if you actually want to move a big rig
you need
tow truck operators and those tow truck
operators know truckers
they know truckers aren't racist they're
not nazis no matter how many times joe
biden and justin trudeau claim they are
so some of them aren't inclined to help
david allen for example is the president
of gary's towing in thunder bay ontario
he told canadian media quote we have all
the capabilities on our tow trucks to do
it but i don't think anyone would want
to
another tow truck operator called randy
wan said that even if tow truck
operators wanted to help carry out pete
butterjudge's orders
it would be very hard quote in the end
the trucker's gonna say whether you're
taking that truck away or not now there
are technical reasons for this which
apparently don't teach at mckinsey it
turns out that trucks are heavy they
have air brakes and steel belted tires
some of the truckers remove their tires
completely so what now
now is when you start to panic and they
definitely are this afternoon the prime
minister of canada who clearly is fidel
castro's illegitimate son came out from
hiding to threaten the protesters
directly watch this
if you joined the protests because
you're tired of kovit
you now need to understand
that you're breaking laws
the consequences are becoming more and
more severe
you don't end up losing your license
end up with a criminal record which will
impact your job
your livelihood
even your ability to travel
internationally including to the u.s
you could be breaking laws that was the
funniest part these are people who
literally don't care about the law at
all they believe they make the law
this is the prime minister who ordered
the cops to steal people's fuel there's
no law that says you can't have fuel in
ottawa he's made that up now he's
lecturing about the law
and joe biden who is violating federal
law on the grand scale every day by
importing two million people illegally
without your consent he's upset about
the law
justin drew is so upset he's threatening
the trucker's children quote it's time
to go home especially if you have your
kids with you trudeau said wouldn't want
something to happen to them
true also attacked the protesters for
closing the border only justin trudeau
is allowed to do that which he has done
for more than a year
so what are we watching here it's more
than hypocrisy
what we're watching is panic
justin trudeau knows that nobody joined
the protest because they're quote tired
of kovid they're tired of tyranny
they're tired of being told to inject
something into their bodies they don't
want whose long-term effects cannot be
known sold by companies that are
protected that have immunity
from public
recourse
we also know
that what they told us to do didn't work
the lockdowns didn't work johns hopkins
came out and said it the other day
pretty conclusive
that's what people are mad about they
want their freedom back they're not
tired of the virus they're tired of the
leaders who use the virus to give
themselves more power
and they're still doing it here's
ontario's premier doug ford he announced
today that instead of lifting his
province's useless mandates he's going
to steal the trucker's money find them
and then send them to jail
there will be consequences for these
actions
and they will
be severe
we've already started by going after the
money funding the illegal occupation
yesterday in ontario court granted our
request
to freeze the funds
from give send goal
for the convoy fines for non-compliance
will be severe with a maximum penalty of
one hundred thousand dollars
and up to a year imprisonment
we will also provide additional
authority
to consider taking away the personal and
commercial licenses of anyone who
doesn't comply with these orders
when you start making threats like that
you've already lost what you're showing
is that you're impotent and that's why
you're unreasonable that's why you're
hysterical that's why you're waving your
arms around telling people they're going
to prison
when you start stealing things from
people outside the law speaking of the
law
everybody knows you're weak
so keep in mind that truckers raised 10
million dollars on gofundme that's a
california company but canadian
politicians had that effort shut down
then give send go which is a delaware
company raised almost the same amount
and canadian politicians went after that
money too
the attorney general of ontario
successfully got a court order to freeze
access to the 8.4 million raised on give
send go those funds were going to an
adopt a trucker fundraising campaign it
was paying for quote housing water food
accommodations and shuttle services for
truck drivers in ottawa but all that
money has just been stolen by the
canadian government it's been seized
all of this is pushing people away from
government issued currencies because
they're in control of lunatics like the
guy you just saw and they're moving
toward cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
just like 18 wheelers on bridges
blockchain is pretty tough for the
authorities to control therefore here's
how you know it's a threat
the crypto guys must be white
supremacists and lo and behold that's
exactly what they're now telling us
it's an avenue
not just to make a lot of money or lose
a lot of money but it's also an avenue
for money laundering and it's also a
place where white supremacists
apparently are taking options i mean
it's problematic at best in so many ways
it's problematic at best how do people
like that get on television there should
be an iq requirement but by putting dumb
people in the anchor chair
they're perfectly compliant to the
people in charge crypto is white
supremacy
but the hysteria gives them away
as a trucker called danielle cerseill
explained in ottawa last night these
people are terrified they're afraid of
losing control the blockade of the
windsor bridge panicked them
they blocked the ambassador bridge yeah
that's the busiest that's the biggest
busiest border crossing in uh
in between canada and usa
the most trade goes to that that port
so
it's it's hidden up good you know
so the downside of all of this is it's
turning canada into a legitimate police
state for real
here's one of doug's ford's police
officers harassing a woman at her home
because of something she wrote on
facebook in support of the truckers it's
one of the creepiest clips you're going
to see today watch
this is just some information about
peaceful protests that's all it is okay
so you saw something on my facebook no
on the facebook group so
the ontario provincial police are
watching what people are doing on
facebook in different groups whether or
not they're commenting participating
liking
and you guys are now doing service calls
to give people information about
peaceful protests it's just a proactive
measure to make sure you understand your
rights about peaceful protesting
it's so great in 2020 the stasi or
chirpy
we're here as a proactive measure to
inform you of your rights not because
we've been spying on your social media
so to recap donating to the truckers is
criminal saying anything positive about
the truckers gets the police to show up
at your house
that's why truckers are the new q anon
russia white supremacist extremist
threat
our leaders in this country agree in
michigan dopiel gretchen whitmer is
plotting to attack them with bulldozers
watch
do police need to begin arresting people
in the blockade
you know i i
i'm not going to weigh into what the
canadi how they proceed i'm going to
tell you right now though they have to
get it done
and using whatever tool it takes to
safely and swiftly end this is is what
we're calling on them to do
trucker-inspired protests
in the u.s potentially in your state
would you forcibly clear
people
brianna if people are breaking the law
uh obviously we'll have we'll assess it
at the time but we are working very
closely with our federal partners and
the state police the fact of the matter
is we're going to do everything we can
to prevent that from happening in the
first place
working closely with our federal
partners says the human mask lady keep
in mind they're not talking about isis
these are truck drivers the people who
bring you food they're unarmed they're
waving canadian flags and talking about
love a lot of them brought their kids
should cnn's national security
contributors and the neoliberal
politicians who are attacking them
really weigh into this fight no because
they can't win it one side is too
sympathetic and the other is too
loathsome but they can't help themselves
they are so threatened by disobedience
they rush forward with swords drawn they
know if canadian truckers can get away
with this the game is over so they must
crush anyone who questions the high
priest of neoliberalism and that
category includes plenty of people on
the right obviously but tellingly it
includes plenty of people who aren't on
the right but just feel like thinking
for themselves
it includes anyone who invests in
bitcoin as we said it includes sikh
truck drivers in ottawa who now work for
putin and joe rogan who's now a racist
and david portnow he's now a sex
offender and tavis smiley who's now a
serial harasser
those aren't right wingers they're just
people who dared to say what they think
that slander hasn't worked
and it won't work here you can't cancel
a bridge full of 18-wheelers and shame
them into driving away
they're going to try it tomorrow there's
going to be a showdown in windsor
ontario we'll see what happens but the
rest of the world has already learned
the lesson
which is
if you resist if you say i've had enough
peacefully cheerfully with love
they have to pay attention the only
thing they pay attention to
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else